visit expressvpn.com
and get three extra months of expressvpn
for free
i was a traditional swing state uh obama
won it and then iol went for
trump by nine points in 2016 and eight
points and 22. yeah and then i also have
to say you know we're talking about when
you're talking about
iowa you're talking about farmland you
know you're talking about people that
were absolutely
hurt with these tariffs and that's a
place where i would think would be the
first place to say
we're done with this with with donald
trump but you're right i mean it's one
of those shocking things when you look
at the end of the election and you go
wow how did he pull it off there people
are concerned
that iowa may not be a swing state
anymore
which would be very very painful and
there are some folks in the democratic
party who are looking at it and saying
well
you know that this isn't really fertile
ground for us anymore
if you're in a place that's going red
like you're losing it in front of your
very eyes
uh and i don't think the national
democratic party takes that stuff very
seriously honestly
they're just like did we win yes all
right moving on what are the new places
we can win
georgia where i am now okay swap out
iowa for georgia done
saying to those people it's like whoop
like we're not competitive here anymore
like you know
like see ya you know is [ __ ] terrible
yeah think about those people they're
like
what do you mean you're leaving what do
you mean you don't care anymore
they feel like they have been absolutely
left out you know to
to just suffer for themselves
[Music]
hey everybody this is zach brownman
andrew's former campaign manager and
co-host yang speaks welcome back
to a special christmas eve episode of
yank speaks
and today's episode we've got an awesome
guest richard ojeda
former congressional candidate from the
great state of west virginia ran a
really compelling
even national race in many ways and has
been fighting to turn west virginia blue
and for a lot of great causes former
army veteran
really really fascinating guy you guys
are going to love it and for those who
are really following the important news
the buffalo bills are afc east champions
merry christmas to all anyway guys i
hope you enjoy this
it's an amazing conversation between two
fascinating individuals
happy holidays to all and enjoy it
[Music]
[Applause]
hey richard it's great to be here yes
this is my brother it is
airborne indeed yeah glad to have you on
here brother this
you know i'm a huge fan and and and it's
just anytime i get the opportunity to
hang out with you
it's a good time so right doctor richard
admired you
and your work for years and then when we
got to connect uh during the campaign
it was a privilege for me and we got
some west virginia talent from you some
of your former staffers came and worked
on the campaign
uh and so i feel like i had a little bit
of your campaign's dna which made me
feel
which made me feel good well it was it
was it was an honor to to go to new york
to spend some time with your team
uh but you know let me just go ahead and
jump right into this conversation here
you know you're down in georgia right
now
and you know we have you know the
president of the united states claiming
all this
voter fraud and all these things right
here you know uh
and and we also know that we have an
opportunity
if those two candidates jon ossoff and
dr reverend warnock actually win we can
flip the senate
and give president joe biden elect a
senate that he can work with
so tell us about what's going on down
there in georgia and
and are there any type of roadblocks
that you're finding in your way
uh i went door to door yesterday in
columbus we had a rally of canvassers
uh and people here in georgia energized
um it's going to be a turnout battle in
my opinion because a lot of folks voted
in november and think well that's it
and then sometimes when you say hey
you're ready to vote again they look at
you like
there's another vote though at this
point they probably
have seen tv ads from one side or
another about this special election
but you're 100 right richard unless we
want mitch mcconnell
playing obstructionist for another two
years minimum
we need these seats and we're seeing
right now if washington has an excuse
not to work
it won't work so we need to do
everything we can to get
senators in place that actually want to
do something and
for years now mitch mcconnell has been
the leader of
not doing anything i said on the trail
yesterday it's like he has a car
pointed at a ditch and all he wants to
do is just run the car and rev the
engine into the ditch
and that's not what the american people
need right now well and i think that
that's absolutely
a perfect conversation because you know
when you realize that one of the main
issues of holding legislation hostage
is mitch mcconnell and we're talking
about legislation that
absolutely you know does away with
gerrymandering
you know requires that more people uh
expose
their donors so that everybody can see
actually where their money is coming
from
we're talking about raising minimum wage
there's just so many things out there
that this guy is basically sitting on to
kill
and to me that is one of the greatest
you know conversations when you let
these people know
that kentucky couldn't sit mitch
mcconnell down but georgia can
that's right we can demote mitch
mcconnell to the minority wouldn't that
be glorious
uh he's he's been again obstructing
any kind of meaningful bills for a long
time
uh and i feel like georgia's a success
story where
if you were to go back eight ten years
and say georgia is going to
have gone for uh the democrat in a
presidential election that
these elections would be so tight people
would be like georgia you know what are
you talking about
and it's one reason why i admire when
you've done so much richard
in fighting for the people of west
virginia but also with no democrats left
behind fighting for the folks in
tennessee in rural florida
in places that democrats need help and
support
and i was staggered by how little
support many many candidates get from
the national democratic party
if the district is red-leaning i feel
like the democrats at this point are
kind of this financial optimization
organization
where they say like what what you know
like we don't think it's a good use of
money and then they spend nothing
uh you have to invest in places for them
to be competitive
and georgia's benefiting from an
investment that took years
from organizers on the ground uh and
folks who've been trying to turn the
state purple for
a long time absolutely you know stacey
abrams has become a hero to the
democratic party
but you know you're absolutely right you
know the democratic party has no problem
dumping money into races against mitch
mcconnell
and lindsey graham when honestly it's
almost impossible to be able to flip
those seats and one of the main reasons
why
is because people in kentucky even if
they don't like mitch mcconnell they
know
mitch mcconnell has a script that he
reads that says look
i'm the senior person in the senate
if you get rid of me and you replace me
with uh amy mcgrath she starts at the
bottom of the ladder
and you know i hate to say it but that's
a that's a pretty good
uh you know argument to have but you
know
one of the things about us with nobody
left behind and and going into red
you know rural america you know there's
people there that are amazing candidates
that have a phenomenal platform
that deserve to be heard and just
because they don't come from money
the democratic party automatically turns
them off and we have to convince them
that those are the races that are the
most important to invest in because we
will never flip
any place from red to blue unless we put
in the groundwork
it's one thing i love about your
organization richard and i had the
pleasure of meeting
some of the candidates you endorsed and
they were tremendous i endured some of
them myself
and wanted to endorse them all honestly
because uh they were
they were tremendous candidates and
human beings i did get behind blair
walsingham obviously who is a yang gang
uh candidate in tennessee uh tom
palsowitz in
wisconsin you could go on and on and
look at adam christensen in florida you
can go on and on and look at the folks i
would actually urge
anyone to dig into the candidates that
were endorsed by no dem left behind
uh and see what they were about because
they were amazing candidates
uh and one of the things this really
deeply affected me richard because i saw
these amazing candidates not just yours
but others
lose in these districts that should have
been very competitive
but the blue wave that many anticipated
did not materialize you actually had
more of a red wave in a lot of places
uh you you had folks who got their vote
count but then it turns out that many
many people came out and voted for trump
that didn't show up in 2016. uh and this
really has shaped my viewpoint on what
we have to do moving forward
uh like where if you're going to have
any kind of governing majority you're
going to need to change it up
you're going to need to invest in places
you haven't invested in you're going to
have to invest in candidates you haven't
invested in in people
places but also you need like different
terms of engagement to use a military
term
where right now you have this clash
that's going on
and no one's really going to win uh
enough to govern
and that's disastrous for us
and what that does is the frustration
goes up the hostility goes up
the polarization goes up and still
nothing happens
so i'm i'm now convinced that that's
actually the fundamental problem that we
have to solve for and your organization
is one of the organizations trying to
help
well you know we're actually you know
hoping that a lot of our candidates
are willing to basically run again in
two years for those seats
you know even though we didn't flip any
seats from red to blue we believe that
we had
amazing candidates that with time
absolutely can
tom palsowicz blair wassingham lindsey
simmons i mean we had
amazing candidates that you know
oh my gosh i mean you know a harvard
graduate she also
happens to be the wife of a helicopter
pilot
in the united states military that is
deployed with a bounty on his head i
mean her story was an amazing story
incredible just absolutely and and those
are the people that you know i really
hope
you know continue in this fight you know
i ran for congress
and and the truth is is that you know i
probably should have ran again for for
that same seat because i
might have had a better chance but in
west virginia honestly
i mean trump has has for some odd reason
convinced these people
that he's practically the second coming
of christ and
and honestly i mean i'll tell you right
now west virginia this last election was
a bloodbath
we lost every single state seat to the
republicans
uh we lost all three of the
congressional seats or
we lost the elections from the three
candidates we had we lost the senate
race
and then in terms of state senate and
the local house of delegates for the
state level
i mean once again the republicans picked
up even more even more uh
seats so there was a red wave in a lot
of the country richard truthfully
uh and uh this book i'm reading now why
we're polarized by ezra klein
actually makes so many compelling points
about how people are voting
and one mistake that we make is that
we're arguing in terms of policy and
impact and it turns out there's actually
a pretty weak
correlation between whether you say
you're conservative
or liberal and what you actually think
about on a list of policies
you know it's very it's at this point
we're kind of in teams or tribes uh
and we have knee-jerk reactions uh based
upon
whether particular terms have been
charged positively or negatively uh
for us uh and and i think that's one of
the
things uh the i take from this cycle is
that
this red wave that happened in west
virginia and texas and
uh west or like a lot of different
places
it's born not of the fact that people
are against common sense measures that
might improve everyone's life
uh it's that right now we're getting
uh turned into teams more or less and
there used to be more of like an
american team
where you you just you know you could
have honest disagreements
this book why we're polarized breaks
down why it's become so much more
pronounced now than it was in past years
and it's very compelling well you know
i'm hoping that the democratic party
is you know looking at this last
election
and really starting to pay attention to
the things that have went on
and trying to basically re-strategize
you know and come back in in 2022
and figure out how we can finally flip
some of these seats from red to blue
i think that we have to i mean it's not
just you know
mitch mcconnell and lindsey graham i
mean you're talking about you know
there's a lot of folks out there that i
believe are absolutely doing harm
to the average citizen out there i mean
you know right now we have a president
that is trying to undermine our
democracy
he's trying to plant a seed in people's
heads that voting
is is a sham and and i mean it's just
it amazes me how many people actually
are
falling they're they're taking that the
the the hook line and sinker you know i
don't understand it
well it's tough we're entering a
post-fact environment richard and it's
very very dangerous
uh you know if you can't agree on facts
then it just really deteriorates quickly
into uh my presenting one version of
reality and you're presenting yours
[Music]
the yang gang is a very creative bunch
we love to learn
we love to interface with folks who are
a little bit ahead of us
on the curve in a particular scale and
one way
to get everything you need from a
creative class or community is
skillshare
skillshare is the world's leading
community of folks who want to
get better and learn from experts it's
an online
learning community that offers
membership with meaning ooh
like that that does that not sound like
us it sounds like us to me
it's also incredibly affordable because
that's also very us we try and keep
things affordable around here
so i i last time i talked about this i
talked about this iphone photography
class i took and now i'm doing
diy do-it-yourself product photography
um
not that i want to be a photographer i
just find it uh helpful
because we take a lot more photos and
you realize and my photos always suck
they
always suck i take a photo of the family
it's all shadowy
everybody looks you look funny you have
three chins whatever it is so you try to
um
i've been learning some cool tips and
tricks on how to be a better
photographer just for like everyday life
which i find helpful
um so if you are interested in
learning more and taking these types of
either creative or thoughtful or
marketing classes skillshare.com is
pretty awesome you just go to
skillshare.com
yangspeaks and get free trap so it's a
free child premium membership
that's one of a kind it can be
personalized and perfectly imperfect
learn a whole bunch of things about what
you put your time
and your effort and it's a great gift
around the holidays to show how much you
care about someone who's looking for
self-improvement and stuff to do during
quarantine
so skillshare.com yankspeaks get your
free trial check it out
it's pretty awesome
[Music]
i'd love to hear more about the work
that no dems left behind is doing i love
the idea of some of these folks like
lindsey simmons running again
because i think that when you run
multiple times people are more familiar
with you they trust you more there's a
sense that oh
like they weren't just uh one and done
um so i hope a lot of these candidates
come back but i'd love to hear
what you've learned through no dems left
behind
and what you would tell the democratic
party to do if you were just sitting
there
opposite the new dnc chair who i think
is going to be jamie harrison
who actually is i think very familiar
with some of these issues because
he was a south carolina state chair in
south carolina in case you hadn't
noticed
is kind of red well once again it comes
down to just investing in these races
you know i mean the problem with the
democratic party
is they initially this is the worst part
is the first thing that they look at is
how much money do you have
and if you don't surprise them with a
massive amount of cash they are so quick
to go
click and turn you off well can you talk
about your experience as a candidate
yourself because you kind of became a
viral sensation when you ran for
congress
you were not the first person to say to
me that the democratic party just tries
to look at how much money you raised
uh and they don't seem to evaluate the
candidate uh
the platform their connection with the
community you know
their appeal uh they just try and and
i'm a numbers guy but on this one
you know you there there's much more to
this picture than number so how did you
get this impression
from the democratic party was it through
your own experience or through your
candidates or what well
you know it was through my own
experience but then i've seen it again
in this snowden left behind but you know
for me
basically we were told right off the bat
that the democratic party doesn't like
my race that my race is unwinnable it
was
r plus 54. they basically just turned me
off
so we won the primary and we won it
pretty big
and then you know it took us literally
about a month and a half
into the general election to where
we finally were able to provide polling
that said
richard ojeda is trending here and
people across the state
on both sides of the aisle are are
liking what i was saying
and it was only when we were able to
show that to
our united states senator joe manchin
and ask joe manchin to try to help us
out a little bit and reach out to the
democratic party
and the d triple c and say hey you need
to give this guy a look
and when they finally did they kind of
stale
they stayed off at a distance but they
started watching us and then when we
started putting together our
our commercials and you know my
commercials and my videos
went viral i mean i mean we had a guy
that was a was a laid off coal miner
that
basically took to youtube and learned
how to become
a a producer i guess you know when he
started
filming my commercials and they caught
on
and it was then that the democratic
party finally said okay we're going to
put you on the red to blue list
and from that moment on i mean it was
phenomenal we raised all kinds of money
and at the end of the day you know we
actually at one time
had polling that showed that we were
winning but you know when you're in an
area like i live in
trump come down there twice he come down
here twice the first time he was in
charleston
he stood on a podium and called me a
stone cold crazy wacko
and of course he introduced my opponent
and then he come back
later and he basically tried to paint me
into
the caravan because he pronounced my
name the way that it's normally
pronounced in in places like mexico
and he tried to tie me and we watched
our poll numbers just
just dropped if it's me and i'm the
democratic party i'm like okay who are
my congressional candidates like
in these races and yeah of course you
have to prioritize somewhat
um but there should be like a baseline
level of support if you get as the
democratic congressional candidate just
about anywhere
[Laughter]
and then if you start showing traffic
and then
you know they can start making
investments i mean part of the issue too
is that sometimes
uh their advice is you know not the
greatest um so
so your experience with uh the no
dams left behind candidates what is the
baseline level of support
a democratic congressional candidate
currently receives in a district that
is not considered uh a swing or
competitive district
like let's say blair walsingham i uh
like wins her
nomination in tennessee like does she
get anything from the democratic party
well that's one of the things is that i
really can't answer that question
they definitely should if they win the
primary they absolutely should but
i do not think that any of our
candidates really received hardly
anything at all
from the democratic party they were
pretty much left out there fighting
their own battles themselves
uh because i i do not believe that any
of our candidates received any support
at all from the d triple c
and then no damn's left behind i i mean
you yourself are not like some mammoth
money grows on trees type organization
uh but you did what you could for them
like what
what did the no damn left behind support
look like well you know we tried
to be able to bring on certain folks
across this country
that could highlight our stories of our
candidates
and that right there did help us to be
able to raise money
it helped our candidates directly with
fundraising you know we had
town halls where you hosted one of our
town halls
we had alyssa milano we've had
just quite a few different folks that
come on and
and and gave our candidates a voice
and that right there you know when you
have alyssa milano
and she's bringing our candidates in
front of
a huge amount of folks that are
interested
in in politics and they like what they
hear
and see that equates to support
and and that's how our candidates were
able to continue fighting
you know and we had amazing candidates
we had mia uh
uh mia mason which was the first female
transgender
uh democratic nominee in maryland's
first district anybody that took the
time to listen to what she had to say
was impressed tom palzowicz
my goodness gracious i mean that guy is
amazing
yeah i was blown away by your candidates
uh and
getting them in front of people is
certainly helpful one thing i heard from
multiple candidates richard you should
you probably already know this
but their favorite thing about your
organization
was the support they got from each other
because it's such
an isolating humbling process running
for office
much less running for congress in a
district that is tilted
significantly against you and so you
feel like
you're alone in it and they had each
other like several of them actually said
to me that being in touch with each
other was profoundly
helpful and promoting each other you
know in their own states
and and when we did those live town
halls you know we were able to uh
we were able to to to know that our our
candidates were getting better support
from other from other states
[Music]
do you know what time it is yang speaks
listeners it's time
to learn about expressvpn
they are the best they are the virtual
private network
rated number one by cnet and wired
don't let your data be hanging out in
the
internet for someone to grab and resell
over and over again don't do it don't do
it instead
get expressvpn you beam into the
internet through their secure servers
and it's like you're a secret agent no
one can find you
your data can't be sold resold that's
expressvpn for you
so if this sounds good to you i mean the
songs sounded terrible i apologize
but if the ideas behind the song sounded
good to you
visit expressvpn.com yang that's
expressvpn.com
to get three months free off of the top
rated virtual private network
by cnet and wired you can beam into the
internet
uh and no one will be the wiser your
data will
stay yours expressvpn.com right now to
learn more
you sound like buddy from elf like will
ferrell and elf when he's singing to his
dad
um he's just making up a song as he goes
which is pretty awesome or like those
improv groups and they try and sing
together the same tune and they don't
know the melody uh which is hilarious
however i'll say this like um
ask yourself like how are you choosing
which internet service provider you use
and the sad thing is most of us
don't have we have very little choice if
you will because these isps operate like
monopolies in the regions that they
serve and then they use that monopoly
power to take advantage of their
customers so data caps and streaming
throttles and
the list goes on and frankly the more
android and i've learned about this the
worse we
feel um and worst of all they log your
internet activity
and they sell that data to other big
tech companies and advertisers
uh which is not right and not fair we're
very very against it and to prevent
that um frankly from seeing my internet
activity we protect
all of our devices with expressvpn so
check it out expressvpn.com
yang and if you go maybe yang will stop
singing probably not though so uh
expressvpn never slashing
[Music]
you know what one place that i spent a
lot of time on the trail was
iowa and i was a traditional swing state
obama won it um it's obviously the first
in the nation
caucus uh and then iowa went for
trump by nine points in 2016 and eight
points in 2020.
and uh people are concerned that
iowa may not be a swing state anymore
which would be very very painful
uh and to me this is an exact
emblem of what's happening with the
democratic party and the
the thing they should fight against so
iowa is a predominantly rural state
uh it's a predominantly white state uh
and there are some folks in the
democratic party who are looking at and
saying well
you know that this isn't really fertile
ground for us anymore
uh and that's catastrophic all of us so
one of the things that i'm suggesting is
like hey democrats
like you need to go to iowa and figure
out why you're losing
you know you know and you probably know
jd scholten
absolutely the candidates there great
guy ran twice
uh and and he's tough yeah an amazing
guy and had a tougher time in 2020 than
in his last race
in part because this red wave we're
describing so that this to me is the
fundamental challenge another state that
had a similar profile
very very swing history
but trump won by eight points or so
twice now is ohio
uh dynamic though ohio is significantly
more diverse
than iowa but but some of these dynamics
are similar you have a state that
represents the agricultural midwest in
iowa
and then the industrial midwest and ohio
used to both be swing states and now
democrats are losing in both of them
and to me what you're doing with no
democrats left behind and what's
happening in those two swing states
formerly swing states uh it's virtually
identical
which is like why can democrats not
appeal to people who live in these
communities
yeah and then i also have to say you
know we're talking about when you're
talking about iowa you're talking about
farmland you know you're talking about
people that were absolutely
hurt with these tariffs and that's a
place where i would think would be the
first place to say
we're done with this with with donald
trump but you're right i mean it's one
of those shocking things when you look
at the end of the election and you go
wow how did he pull it off there yeah
abby finkenauer incumbent democrat
uh lost her bid for re-election uh so
that hurts i mean i know a lot of these
iowa democrats
and it's painful uh you know like if
you're
in a community so it's hard enough what
you do with no democrats left behind or
in west virginia we're in your community
that's very very red leaning and then
you're trying to make the case with
democratic party that's very very
difficult
you know what may even be more difficult
is when you're making the case in a
place that is going red
around you because at least when you
start out
in a place that's kind of low frankly
then you're like okay
no place to go but up from here you know
like we like we're heading in a good
direction
i've got a lot to build off a lot of
untapped potential uh whereas if you're
in a place that's going red like you're
losing it in front of your very eyes
uh and i don't think the national
democratic party takes that stuff very
seriously honestly they're just like did
we win
yes all right moving on what are the new
places we can win
georgia where i am now okay swap out
iowa for georgia done
and uh and then you're just like well
that doesn't solve our problems it
doesn't keep us from polarizing
uh and i happen to know now hundreds
maybe thousands of democratic activists
in uh iowa i mean hopscotch that state
you know went to county event after
county event and so saying to those
people it's like whoop
like we're not competitive here anymore
like you know like see ya
you know is [ __ ] terrible yeah think
about those people they're like
what do you mean you're leaving what do
you mean you don't care anymore
you know i mean they feel like they have
been absolutely left out
you know to to just suffer for
themselves that's what we have to try
and
steer away from again it's one reason i
feel so strongly about no dems left
behind in the work you do is that i feel
like you're helping lead us
in that direction where the democrats
are actually trying to solve problems in
communities
that are not uh super hospitable you
know like that to me has to be the point
well you know we like to say we go into
red rural districts and we pick a fight
and the truth is is we're at the point
now where we're gonna have to
sling it out with everybody because it
continues to get redder and redder and
redder
it is getting redder and redder richard
i have some
some reasons in my mind as to why that's
happening i mean a lot of it is that
if you have a mindset of scarcity uh
then you become
much more susceptible to suggestions
that
uh these institutions aren't working
[Music]
i am a dad and
i am always getting invited to dad
things
and then you're like what kind of prezi
does this kid want and you have no clue
what that other
that other family's kid wants no it's
true you're like i have no idea what
your kid likes
uh and then you just take a guess and
you're just like all right i guess that
you know
as long as i i fulfilled my social
obligations we're okay but you know what
the kids actually would
love they would love a subscription book
club that sends five beautiful
children's books
to the family every month and picked by
experts
tell me that all of the parents you know
would not love you for that
know what i mean like if they're
struggling with their kids and as a
parent i'll tell you
like you're always just trying to stay
one step ahead of um
you know whatever your kids uh wants and
needs are if you could set it and forget
it where you just get sent five
uh kids books that are curated and
appropriate
that's a game changer for parents and
this makes a phenomenal gift
gift subscriptions are available for 1 3
6 or 12 months of books
so you could go the whole year and being
like i'm going to get you 12
gift boxes of books you probably need to
be related to that person or you could
give them like one or three months
if you know it's not that big a deal to
you so this is the gift
that's going to knock it out of the park
for all the parents
in your life go to literati.com
yang for 25 off your first two orders
and pick your kids book club gift today
no one else has kids book clubs like
this
only at literary.com yang can you get 25
off your first two orders and receive
five kids books curated by experts
delivered to your door or your friend's
door
every month that's literati.com yang
make someone's holiday season actually
like just be the gift that keeps on
giving this year
[Music]
the fact is a lot of our institutions
are not working and this is one of the
other traps of the democratic party in
my mind is that if you're
like the party that's arguing that
things are working
and then other people like no no they're
not working like it becomes a
progressively harder
case to make that institutions are
working when we can all look around us
and be like i'm not sure things are
working so well
i mean congress and its failure to get
out any kind of
uh relief bill between april and
december i mean that's a colossal
failure
uh and that's on everyone um
but you know the the institutional
failures are all around us
and i think it's it's one reason why
you're seeing this
growth in enthusiasm among some
folks who are kind of outside the system
right now because the system's not
working for a lot of people
yeah and i think that's one of the main
reasons why donald trump was able to
take hold
is he capitalized on that drain the
swamp i'm going to break things up i'm
going to do things differently a lot of
americans were like yeah
and there was like a significant amount
of me that was like okay i get that
appeal i get it um
now i was still staggered that you know
another six million americans decided to
double down on him
uh after watching his style of
governance fail miserably
uh so that was jarring to me uh and
i think that's like a very clear red
flag i took a giant red flag from 2016
it got me to run
where i said okay this is not working uh
and to me the problem is that we blasted
away millions of manufacturing jobs
in the swing states michigan ohio
pennsylvania wisconsin
um and we're gonna do the same thing you
know how i think about this
like to retail jobs call center jobs and
eventually truck driving jobs
i believe all still is happening more
than ever it's speeding up
just because of the pandemic and
i took another red flag from 2020 which
is that
the polarization is growing the sense of
institutional failure is growing
and we don't have unlimited time uh you
know i
i i do think that democrats need to
really dig deep and figure out okay like
why do so many americans feel like
[ __ ] is now working for them you know i
i
agree wholeheartedly you know i'm
sitting here and i'm wondering you know
how on earth does donald trump still
have
so many supporters when i don't see
i mean i see him shutting down the
government
i see him turning his back on the kurds
i see him
ignoring a global pandemic
that he and many of those that were in
those rooms
knew that would come across us and
absolutely decimate
uh families across this country and i
just don't understand how
he still has the support that he has i
mean i'm glad that
that you know joe biden has broken all
records
but it still makes me sad when i look
and realize
yeah it's a giant fight for all of us it
is i mean 70 some million people still
supported
donald trump and we're talking about a
man who has
golfed more than anything we're talking
about a man who has made america hate
again
and has done things against our allies
and they still support him what can you
do
and that's the big question for the
democratic party what can we do
now we need to make different kinds of
appeals i think we need to broaden the
way we speak to folks i think again we
need to
invest in communities that right now we
are not investing in
um we have to
try and get behind people as well as
numbers to your point and i'm the math
guy saying that so you know
think about that uh that there there
needs to be a
soul-searching process for the
democratic party quickly quickly because
we
don't have unlimited time i mean to eke
out a victory against donald trump and i
know we want to buy a lot in the popular
vote
um but we lost five
house seats last i checked uh and the
democrats thought they were going to
gain five to 15 which i would have
agreed with before the fact because like
you i'd be like well no one's going to
vote for this guy after all of this
i mean i thought he'd get his his base
but i didn't think there would be all of
these
new supporters i didn't think it was
going to be um
this close in a lot of play but again it
like it wasn't just close in a lot of
places republicans won
like a lot of these races republican
beat abby finkenauer
you know beat democrats that had won
uh in past cycles so there's something
really
important going on on the ground and we
just don't have unlimited time
uh you know i i ran for president apart
because i was like look we just don't
have time
this stuff's getting faster and nastier
very very quickly and even i
underestimated
how bad it is now uh you know it it's
wild like you almost can't
overestimate how nasty things are
getting
yeah you know i i tell people and it's
it's kind of a joke but it's really not
a joke
i tell them especially where i'm from
here in west virginia i said look you
could wrap a daggone
piece of dog [ __ ] in a damn trump napkin
and these people would vote for it
and the truth is is that there's a lot
of truth in that
[Music]
it's month 18 of the quarantine it's not
quite month 18 but it sure feels like it
uh and one of the things that's harder
and harder for all of us
is to eat healthy to take care of
yourself uh to feel good about yourself
day to day
if you don't take care of yourself then
nothing else works and one way you can
take care of yourself
is by putting good stuff in your body
athletic greens is a
product where they've put together
75 vitamins minerals whole food sourced
ingredients
into one mixture you put it in water you
drink it
and then your body feels energized all
day
athletic greens is really the the name
for this thing because
there's a lot of good stuff going into
your body that you know you need
you're not going to get unless you're
like consuming tons of salads and
vegetation i can't speak highly enough
about the fact that this stuff
really does feel like you're treating
your body better and your body rewards
you for it
so if this sounds like something that
would help you get through
your weeks go to yang
athleticgreens.comyang
get a free year's supply of vitamin d
and
travel packs in addition uh to your
order that's
athleticgreens.comyang get more athletic
become greener
[Music]
i was in south carolina with jeremy and
johnson did you meet jermaine on the
trail i was there to swearing in
the other day i didn't jermaine
heart of gold great candidate uh won his
state rep seat
in south carolina first time candidate
beat a 50 year incumbent by
40 points he's a 35 year old
former professional basketball player
who got his doctorate and
uh you know has been helping people he's
like just a great great guy great
candidate
but one of his fellow reps um was a
retiree who didn't even campaign and
retired like in 2006 so she hasn't even
worked in 14 years and didn't campaign
just put her name on a
republican line against a democratic
incumbent
like everyone ignored the race because
it was a democratic incumbent state rep
who is well known and well liked
against like a total non-factor
and you know how the story ends uh the
retiree won
despite not campaigning a day um so
jermaine when he gets there he's uh you
know at the state house and then one of
his
new fellow reps is this retiree who just
put her name and just everyone went and
voted
r uh you know so so that there's a lot
of voting going on
um that isn't based on principal or the
candidates or
platforms there's just a lot of folks
showing up and uh
pushing r or d uh and
um that's like a very painful reality
where jermaine tells me the story and
i'm just like oh no
you know like that there i mean some of
the candidates adam christensen
who you both you and i supported his
opponent seemed awful
like truly awful uh and and
part of you is like no way that person's
gonna get into congress but you know
like um she's gonna be sworn in in
january so
uh it's painful richard well after after
my race
uh you know i've realized that you know
nothing
nothing should surprise you when you're
talking about politics you know i mean i
put boots on the ground in every single
county in the third congressional
district
i did everything to answer anybody's
questions
live videos almost every night to answer
anybody's questions
and i got beat by a person that refused
to speak to the news refused to answer
any questions from constituents and
basically just said
whatever trump wants is what i'm going
to do boom and she won
yeah it's really tough on a lot of
candidates when they see this
now i read something that struck me as
also painful but kind of accurate
said that when you're in one of these
campaigns it's like you're in one of
those hot air balloons and you're
throwing things overboard or like making
just like decisions to try and like turn
and steer
and then where the balloon winds up is
more result of the weather than anything
else
like you're controlling these things but
then like if the wind blows you
uh you know um you know toward the
ocean or whatever like that's where you
wind up so
i mean uh that's what happened to a lot
of these candidates you know like you
control what you can control
um but then like if the wind blows in a
direction it's tough because a lot of
people aren't paying that close
attention
um and to the extent they they get
motivated they get motivated by the
weather
tell me something you're down there on
the ground in georgia
uh are you feeling any uh
negativity concerning you know where
where donald trump is basically
saying that uh you know obviously the
election
is is a hoax and and now we're also
you know hearing rumors that some people
are even talking about boycotting
if the republicans boycott and i'll tell
you right now this is what i want to
make sure people understand
if you hear people saying that
republicans are going to boycott a race
don't you dare
think that that's true you better make
sure that every single person out there
that is a democrat
is absolutely going to those polls and
casting their votes
because it's no different than looking
at polls and saying aye we're up in the
polls we don't have to worry about it
because that's how you get beat what am
i seeing here
uh uh one thing i will say is that i
think senator
david perdue has a stronger real
connection with the community than
senator kelly lefler does kelly lefler
never got elected got appointed
after making a large donation uh to the
republican party
um they've both been tarred with insider
trading
issues where when they heard about the
coronavirus they
went and bought and sold stocks i mean
like that's a real
uh leadership type activity it's like
you know if if your
country is going to get ravaged by a
pandemic you better adjust your stock
portfolio
um so uh i i feel like in a vacuum i
think kelly lefler would be much much
more vulnerable
but as it is to our earlier discussion
people are going to show up and vote d
or r
so you have to assume in my mind that
either democrats are going to get both
or democrats are going to get neither
do i think that there's some republican
mixed messaging going on oh yeah
like that there there's a lot of
confusion and mixed messaging going on
uh and there are some republicans who
seem concerned that that's not gonna
help them
um i think they're probably right you
know that the
it's interesting richard when you talk
about like the anti-institutional
sentiment that's coming up i mean the
biggest anti-institutional sentiment is
is the folks being like yeah this
election was rigged like the votes
aren't
being counted etc uh and so it's hard to
get people who are that
mistrustful to vote you know what i mean
like that that's
so that's something the republican party
is trying to balance right now
uh i i think they are going to lose at
least a handful of votes at the margins
now you and i both know how horrible it
was
for them to commit insider trading
especially after getting
private briefings that the regular
citizens don't get and they absolutely
did exactly what
you know you would think that corrupt
people would do
but the problem that i believe is a lot
of people act like that's not a big deal
because the majority of people in this
country
don't play in the stock market because
they can't afford to
so they may not look at that as as big
as crime as it is but it is a
absolute big crime with what they have
done
i mean you know kelly loffler i mean
we're talking about she's worth 500
million dollars that's her net worth
and that's not enough it's not enough
for her
she has to try to do underhanded tactics
to get even
more and that is horrible when you think
about it
well sometimes richard money gets into
someone's bloodstream in a way where
it's just like you know
there's never enough uh and one of the
things that happens
is that if the person's on your team
then you'll be like well it wasn't so
bad
uh and that there is like an issue here
that is very very fundamental i don't
know how to address it
it's that the democrats have become the
party of moralizing where they say look
you know
you should not do this you should not do
that and a lot of the stuff i 100 agree
with when they're saying something like
hey you should wear a mask i'm like yes
everyone should wear a mask i mean like
you know what's the harm you get some
uh people from sickness and births um
and so if democrats come and say hey you
shouldn't
you you shouldn't insider trade
odd information you're getting like at
this point i think trump has shattered
all these norms where uh he's gone
around
uh just doing whatever the heck and a
lot of problems like yeah yeah and then
when you come along and say hey you
probably shouldn't be
uh asking you know a foreign leader to
try and investigate your political rival
they're just like ah whatever whatever
you know like and this is something this
whatever impulse
uh is getting stronger and stronger um
because
we have like these institutional lines
of behavior and you know
obviously you're a patriot you fought
and been wounded for a country
like you have a very very strong belief
in right and wrong and so if someone
does something wrong you're like oh
that's completely trash and you know how
the hell can you vote for someone who's
going to do that
when you're like an exemplar of uh
personal
sacrifice uh that those kinds of
guard rails are deteriorating before our
eyes
like if there's someone who just shows
up and uh you know just says like ah
hang it like don't do this don't do that
doesn't matter
there are millions of americans now who
get on board with that
and and this is something that it's
going to be very very difficult to
come back from to overcome it's
something that
i'm struggling with all the time now
because if you're an environment where
again people don't have the same set of
facts and it's like very very hard
um and people's trust has been declining
for years
we've got a very tough trust rebuild
ahead of us if everything were to go
right and you had a government that had
its act together in a society that had
its act together
but we don't you know so we have this
kind of dysfunctional seized up
government trying to solve bigger
problems than ever
well you know one of the things also you
know is is this whole you know covert 19
piece
and it amazes me how so many people have
fell for the it's a fake it's a hoax you
know and donald trump
actually stated that you know after
november the third you wouldn't have to
worry about wearing your mask again
because the hoax would be gone
and we have so many people 2 500 plus
every day now and it's gonna it's going
to stay that way until the inauguration
and
it's going to go on past that until we
can make sure that everybody gets the
vaccine
and we can finally get out in front of
this about you know the hundred days of
wearing a mask
you know it just amazes me how many
people are willing to
sacrifice themselves over
you know they don't have a doctorate you
know
but they automatically all of a sudden
now all these people are experts
in medicine again richard this is
something um
that i'm learning too um so let's say
i'm a media organization
uh and what i do is i present things
that i think are factual and
fact-based and say hey here are rational
responses here's a rational thing to do
and let's say millions of americans now
are having what you'd consider to be
not super rational responses let's say
you know deciding that the chronovirus
hoax is that that wearing a mask is a
bad idea and a bunch of other things
uh so one approach is to be like what
the heck you doing you know like the the
facts are clear
uh the thing i'm trying to grapple with
now you know a lot of me feels that way
uh is to say okay like why are you
acting what i consider
irrationally because at this point it's
not like a handful of people it's like
millions of people
uh and then you look around and say what
are the conditions that have
put you in a position where you are now
acting irrationally
and and there are a lot of conditions
that are being created around the
country
that have pushed a lot of people into
depression anxiety stress
and even pre-covid you know there there
was like a
an increased uptick in receptiveness to
what i'd consider
unreason uh and so that that's the tough
part richard is that like you know if
you're arguing from reason
now um the audience is getting smaller
and smaller
um like the audience for on reason is
getting bigger and bigger
and the audience for on reason is
getting fueled by the internet
in social media and whatnot untruth
misinformation spread six times more
quickly and powerfully than fact
uh so to the extent you start with like
a kernel of unreason it just grows and
grows over time
uh and then people like you and i are
looking at it saying okay like why
are people not listening what is going
on um
and like that's
that's the fundamental problem it's like
and the the answer is not necessarily to
like yell the reasonable thing louder
though
in this case like i'm all for it i'm
happy to myself get a vaccine publicly
and say look i think this is a good idea
you know we're gonna we're gonna need it
um so like i'm gonna do my part but
there are
these conditions that are breeding
irrationality
uh at much much higher levels part of
its economic deprivation
uh part of its institutions that uh are
seem to be responsive uh you know like
people feel like they're increasingly
shut out
your town is disintegrating like the one
restaurant in your town shut down like
you know like
there are conditions that are making
people very very um
subject to poor reasoning and thinking
every public official and leader should
be
speaking from the same script honestly
you know like that to me would have been
a must
if we were going to maintain some level
of uh
consensus around some of the measures
we're taking i'm going to share two
stories
that speak to this directly richard
where some people who work at a hospital
um treating coronavirus patients and
then the coronavirus patients and like
their last
moments instead of uh reaching out to
family members and trying to say their
goodbyes they were angry
or they were still in denial they were
like this can't be happening because
uh they did not believe in the
coronavirus until it had hit them
um that that really hurt me to think
about
uh and that i think that that is
happening uh but there's another story
that's
kind of uh you know it's a major
business story right now or a human
interest story but like
it's someone i knew um and you mentioned
you know harvard but there's an
entrepreneur tony shea who founded
zappos
did have you seen the story at all
richard uh so tony shea is the very
first entrepreneur
um he sold zappos to amazon for over a
billion dollars
wrote a bestselling book called
delivering happiness um
in 2010. um did you use zappos at all
it's like the online shoe store
no i no they're they have excellent
customer service
anyway um fast forward uh he
um he passed away
last week uh and all of this
news has come out that he was struggling
with isolation
and addiction and this is someone who
is a famous entrepreneur worth hundreds
of millions of dollars conservatively
um and then he got himself to a state
where
unfortunately it looks like he was under
the influence of various substances
he seemed to have a lot of um
flammable materials around i mean he
passed away in a fire from
smoke inhalation and like that and this
hit me because i
knew tony uh you know he actually
donated to my campaign
um he and i were um if we weren't
friends we were very friendly
um i certainly would never have imagined
this
happening to him but then you know after
the fact you kind of
think about it and be like wow like who
knows someone's on that path so the
reason i'm bringing him up is because
like in my mind he's like a victim of
the coronavirus in a different way like
he didn't wind up
dead of the coronavirus like in a
hospital where um you know
he was directly um ill but because of
the isolation
and uh the change mental state because
he he was someone who surround himself
with people customarily and then because
of circumstances he was much more
isolated and ended up
in some kind of uh spiral um
that to me is like a metaphor of what a
lot of americans are struggling with
right now
and if a harvard educated centre
millionaire entrepreneur can fall victim
to it and pass away
uh you know like there are people who
are struggling with very basic material
needs who are struggling in similar ways
um so so that's just something that i've
been um
thinking a lot about because you know
when when someone you know dies i mean
it always hits you
so richard what is next for no damn left
no dems left behind
well nobody left behind right now is
looking at some new ways
of being able to you know select the
candidates
uh you know we want to actually allow
the people
you know the people that donate the
money we want them we want to basically
introduce them to all these people that
are potentially going to be
on the no dim left behind list and
you know we want to allow the people to
hear their platforms
see what they're doing and then let the
people decide yep that's the one that we
want to support
and this one and this one and this one
and and we take it from there you know
we don't have
the luxury of being able to say that we
can support a candidate in every single
state across the country
we're still a new organization that you
know is is
is always trying to raise money to get
to allow us to be able to reach out to
more people
but we believe that this will be a way
that can also
get our candidates more support if the
average citizens out there are saying
that's the one
then we're hoping to be able to allow a
bigger group of people to see that and
hopefully they will also commit
i love no down left behind i i think
you're a force to help keep our country
together
really and to make the case that people
that right now
don't think that the democratic party uh
is investing in them in their community
doesn't think it's speaking to them
i love the candidates that i've met
through your organization
uh and i think more people should be
paying attention to what you all are
doing
um i think jamie harrison is going to be
receptive to it too
yeah absolutely you know i hope to get
uh some face time with jamie harrison
you know
my story is one that i believe that they
could also use to try to
improve upon do you know jamie richard
i've never met jamie harrison i'd be
absolutely elated to meet him but you
know
i said this before i said it on actually
the morning joe
and i said i'm sick and tired of showing
up with a for a fight
where the democrats are carrying pillows
and the republicans are wearing brass
knuckles
it's time for the democratic party to
knuckle up and that's exactly what needs
to happen oh
i'm happy to say that and we're counting
our chickens a little bit because it
might not you know jamie hasn't been
named yet
but if jamie harrison is named dnc chair
i will personally introduce the two of
you because i think the two of you need
to
to be connected well i'll tell you right
now i look forward to that
and the yang gang is a force to be
reckoned with
but it absolutely i believe is going to
continue to grow because of the things
that you say
you know uh the the ubi concept is huge
i hope that uh you know your future has
you once again
throwing your hat in the ring uh but uh
i want to take this opportunity and i
want to thank you personally
you know you're a friend of mine uh
we've spent some time together
and i just want to say thank you for
your friendship and thank you for being
you brother
thank you richard i'm pr i feel
privileged to consider you a friend as
well i mean you fought and bled for our
country
uh you fought for the people of west
virginia now you're doing it around the
country
uh you're an awesome patriot well
brother hey you take it easy tell the
family i said hey
tell your people that i said hey and
i'll see you soon brother
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you